مساعدات ضخمه منذ بدايه الحرب ادت لتقويه
الجيش الاوكراني على المدى الطويل حتى رغم
الخسائر الضابط الاسترالي المتقاعد ماي
كراين اعتبر ان اوكرانيا ربما لديها افضل
جيش في العالم الان بسبب خبره الجنود
الميدانيه خلال الثلاثه عشر شهرا الماضيه
مجله نيوزويك نقلت عن باحث في معهد روكينج
قوله ان القوات الاوكرانيه تزداد قوه كل
اسبوع مع بنائها خبره قتاليه متواصله اضاف
الباحث ان جيوش الولايات المتحده والصين
وبريطانيا لا تحصل على التجربه نفسها لعدم
مشاركتها في قتال مثل ذلك دائر بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا منذ اندلاع الحرب في
فبراير من العام الماضي شهدت القوات
المسلحه لاوكرانيا تغييرات كبيره وبعدما
كان الجيش مسلحا باسلحه تعود الى الحقبه
السوفييتيه بات تتصل لاوكرانيا احدث
الاسلحه الغربيه من دبابات وصواريخ وغيرها
لكن رغم هذه الاعتبارات يبقى حجم القوات
المسلحه لدوله ما احد الاعتبارات المهمه
ووفقا للبيانات التي نشرتها مؤسسه
ستاتيستا للبيانات في فبراير كان لدى
روسيا ما يقدر بواحد فاصل 31 مليون شخص
مدرج في القوائم العسكريه مقارنه بخمس مئه
الف في اوكرانيا من بين هذه الارقام كان
لدى روسيا
831 الف جنديا في الخدمه بينما كان لدى
اوكرانيا
الف جندي وايضا كان لدى كلا البلدين قوه
احتياطيه
قوامها 250 الف شخص